a coders I'm Cody and welcome to
learning the basics of regex and
JavaScript so start off what is right X
right reg X is a way to match certain
patterns inside of a string so for
instance together string all your base
are belong to us and you want to test
does base exists in the string you can
do that with reg X so just to show you
that I'll say all your base are belong
to us and if I want to test if base
belongs in the string I can just do the
regex expression / base / end and notice
here we're using around X 101.com which
I highly recommend it's like the best
online regex tester to kind of learning
at your hands wet with reg X so again we
type the regex expression base in our
test string and you see that a
highlights in blue so we know that our
reg X passes so how do you do this in
JavaScript well first of all you want to
declare my string called all your base
are belong to us secondly declare some
type of regex expressions so we start
that with a slash forward slash type in
your X expression
base and then end it with the following
slash and then lastly if you wanted to
test to see if base belongs inner string
we can say is existing and we can say
red X dot test against our string and go
ahead and print out is existing I'll
save that file and I'll go ahead and run
Reggie XJS and we see that a prints out
true so again very similar to the app on
the right if the blue shows up in this
string it's a true and if it doesn't
show up it's gonna be false right so
just to demonstrate that I'll go ahead
and get rid of base I'm gonna rerun reg
X on Jas and see that it prints out
false down here so again this the real
basics just how do you test see if a
certain substring exists in a larger
string so we show that in reg X 101.com
and we're also showing it in JavaScript
over here so now that we learned the
basics of testing assuring let's go
ahead and learn more complicated regex
expressions so the first thing I'm going
to cover is the caret sign and the money
the carrot is used to specify the start
of the string has to match the Rezac
support expression followed by our
string bass and the money sign is used
for designating the in diverse ring so
what does that mean basically it means
that our string has to be bass and
that's it right so all your base are
belong to us won't match but if I change
this to bass it passes again to
demonstrate how you break that I'll add
an extra character called a and notice
that the money sign expression makes it
fail if I were to remove the money sign
it passes again and then again to
demonstrate the carrot sign this thing
it has to start with a bass right so if
I were to change the Z this fails and if
I get rid of the carrot it passes again
and again I'm not going to show this
show how to do this in JavaScript cuz
it's gonna be the same you pretty much
just gonna copy and paste it in and
that's how you do it so a lot of these
examples I'm going to stick to red X 101
okay so we learned simpler in zigs
expressions for testing we're learning
the carrot sign which means cert
position at the stirrup string and we
learn the money sign which means a
certain position at the end of the
string so some other cool things we can
do is let's say we have a string my name
is Cody and my age is 26 26 right okay
so let's say we wanted to make sure that
the string has name is something in it
so again in your regex you can say name
is and then what we want to do now is
test that there's a array of characters
or lengths of characters which are all a
through Z so in this case we can use
something called character classes and
those are designated with square
brackets square brackets or square
braces so I can say anything through a
through Z lowercase and notice that this
will only match the first C so with
character classes you need to add some
additional options so it can be one or
more which is the plus sign
it can be the star which means zero or
more there's a couple others like zero
is optional you don't need to have a
seat and then we can also do let's say
we're checking for a length so we want
to want the four characters I can kind
of go over those later on so let's just
stick with the basics so again we're
looking for it name is you know some
blank fill in the blank with whatever
name you want so we're going to go ahead
and do a plus sign and that'll match any
name so we change this to Bob or Lisa or
whatever it's going to match that and
again we can do the same thing with ages
so if I would change this to age and
then it changes the character class to
zero through nine one or more again any
character that we add which is a digit
should match this regex expression in
the moment we change this to an A or B
or C is going to fail so again as a
recap we just covered character classes
which again is designated by these open
brackets and inside here we can add
ranges of characters we can also add
like let's say we only want it to be one
two or three for the age so then I was
here if I do 99 that'll fail 22 will
pass one two three passes zero two will
fail and you can just mess around with
this to kind of make sure you understand
what's going on and then the same thing
with name if we were to go back and say
we want a through Z and then also
without capitalized letters this will
match with capital Cody or lowercase
Cody does really matter because we're
matching any character which has
lowercase a through Z or uppercase a
through z one or more so you can do even
more you know crazy stuff with this so
if you wanted to add you know alpha
numerics into there we can do so that'll
pass let me go crazy with this read some
more documentation on this but we're
we're just going to cover the very the
basics of regex and using in javascript
we're going to dive deep into how to
define more complicated character
classes so again we covered testing a
string for a substring the carrot the
Money signed character classes we
covered what the plus means what the
star means which is zero or more so
again this will pass if we have nothing
good just at and so zero or more
characters this is a pass this will pass
this will pass in fact just to
demonstrate this let's get rid of the
additional checks so this pack this will
fail because you know there's no
character a through Z here we can also
use the question mark which allows us an
optional I so for instance if we said
the Y's optional on my name this will
pass if I have Kody or if I have Co D
because why are the question mark
represents an optional character and
then lastly I'm not sure if I just
covered this but if I wanted age to be
three characters and only three
characters I could say again the
character class D through nine but in
this case I want it to be one to three
characters so one will pass 12 will pass
one two three will pass but one two
three four will fail and technically it
doesn't fail because you're still
getting that retic string but we'll only
match it against these first characters
so if you want it to explicitly end the
string so if I want to like you know the
end of the character or end of the
string we can just end it with the money
sign and the last thing if we just
wanted to check that it has one
character or one digit in it we could
just add one right so the age is one
so now that we covered character classes
let's cover a couple of special
characters that we can use in rigid
expressions which allow us to instead of
having to write like you know with the
character class zero through nine we can
instead just do slash D so slash D plus
means match one or more arbitrary
strings of digits slash D for it stands
for digits if I do name is I can do
slash W which kind of matches just like
a name asaji W is any word character
equal to a through Z capital A through Z
zero through nine or underscore so
that's more used for like variables or
whatnot we can test for spaces so I
wanted to say verify there's a space in
here I can do slash s so if I don't have
a space that fails I can test for a
newline character so this will fail
unless there's a new line here and you
slash t for tabs there's a bunch of
other ones but I'm not going to cover
all those alright so that's really cool
we can test if string matches a certain
pattern but sometimes or most of the
times you actually want to extract that
string that you found and use it in your
program so for instance let's say we
have a string that says my name is Cody
but we want to actually use the name and
store it in a variable inside of our
code so in that case we can use
something called grouping so I'll go
ahead and surround this character class
with a through z one or more with
parentheses around it and what grouping
allows you to do is in the code we can
say give me matching index 1 and we can
set that into a variable print that out
or do whatever we want so in JavaScript
how do we actually do that again we can
change string to this my name is Cody
the red X will be the exact same as what
we saw here
and now what we can do instead of using
the method test so is that a regex
test we do read tricks on exe c4 execute
on the string and then that will give us
a match so in this case we can say if
match else console dot log no match and
then if there's a match let's say we
just want to print out the name that the
person provided we can say console dot
log name you say constant name is equal
to match of index 1 so if I were to run
this we see that it prints out Cody
right because that is the group of index
1 which again in reg X 101.com we see
its group 1 this is the whole blue
string is group 0 and then let's say for
instance now we change name to something
else so and here we say Zach and then we
print this out or run this file again
it's gonna print out Zach now there is
no name let's just say we have a bunch
of characters or digits there for
whatever reason this should print out no
match because match is going to be
undefined at this point because regex ID
exe C failed so that's the basics of
grouping so if we wanted to do something
a little bit more complicated so for
instance we have a string of separated
file names so we can save file a dot you
know mp3 we have file 0 1 dot mp3 we
have files your to mp3 we have tests USB
and we have other dot txt if we wanted
to take apart this string and find
everything which matches on mp3 and just
grab the grouping of the file name we
can do so like this so again we're
testing for mp3 so flat D
in d3 and then we want global so in this
case we're going to have to add a global
flag here to match anything in this
string because without the global flying
it just matches the first instance and
that's it and then let's say the file
name is any word like so and we need to
extract that so let's go ahead and add a
grouping on it so again this regex gives
us any file which matches on mp3 at the
end and also gives us the group of the
name so to use this in JavaScript let's
go ahead and change string up here to
our list of file names as update or X
here to be any slash word one or more
followed by mp3 and then set that to a
global then we execute that regex Honor
string like we did before and now in
this case what we can do is instead of
just saying if match we say while
there's a match match is equal to red X
unique CC string and I can say console
name is equal to match 1 now go ahead
and run that something it's because I
had that as a constant I need to be able
to redefine it so I'll go ahead and run
that again so notice here prints out
file a file 0 1 in file 0 2 so looking
at the code let's you know walk through
this and figure out what's going on ok
so this we're going to test the regex
against the string and for every time
you find anything it's going to set
match equal to the next file that it
finds
so that's why we can kind of loop
through it and keep calling mash equals
ready to excite exe C
times so the first step is on line seven
we grab the first grouping you print out
the file name and then we do it again
we're just going to keep on traversing
anything that matches that it'd be three
multiple times so again another recap we
learned how to test projects against a
string to see if it something exists in
it and then we also test how to use
groupings to extract certain data from
the regex so again I can go on and on
with all the different you know special
cases of regex but I think what the best
thing you should do is to just keep on
trying new things like think in your
head of different sharing examples or
real-life scenarios in which you need to
extract certain things from a string
save them to a variable print them out
or store them in something and then just
trying different expressions make sure
you understand what's going on mess
around with all the different red X
flags you can use such as it's C
insensitive means case ignore I don't
even know what some of these mean but
honestly I think the most important ones
would be global or case sensitive and
then know that Ren Dex kind of applies
to any programming language so as long
as you have a good understanding of how
to write your etics expressions you can
translate the JavaScript Python Ruby
bash whatever you want you can translate
read x2 and it really helps you out down
the road if you need to do some type of
string manipulation or string matching I
think that kind of wraps up you know how
to use the basis of basics of regex in
JavaScript and again find other
resources if you want a more deep
detailed information about regex but I
think that's a general overview of how
to use regex and java scripts to get
most of the things you're trying to do
complex at least for beginners alright
remember to subscribe and like if you
thought this tutorial is pretty good be
sure to leave feedback and ask any
questions in the comment section of the
video and again thank you so much for
watching